"Неофіт у політиці", "темна конячка", "рідкісна сенсація" -
західні ЗМІ не шкодували епітетів щодо коміка Володимира Зеленського
і його перемоги у першому турі президентських виборів в Україні.
Своїми версіями причин перемоги шоумена охоче діляться і європейські політики.
Голосування за Зеленського вони називають ляпасом чинній українські владі,
зокрема з огляду на низку корупційних скандалів.
Проте думки щодо можливого президентства шоумена у євродепутатів розділилися.
Член комітету Європарламенту із закордонних справ,
представник фракції Європейської народної партії у Європарламенті Ельмар Брок побоюється,
що Україну може очолити людина без політичного досвіду.
Звісно, я стурбований, тому що ми насправді нічого не знаємо про нього,
в якому напрямку він рухається.
Хоча він заявляв, що хоче зберегти європейські договори.
Але залишається якась непевність у цих питаннях,
тому що він не має політичного досвіду і не знає політичних тонкощів.
Схожі побоювання і у депутата Бундестагу,
речника із зовнішньополітичних питань ХДС Норберта Реттґена.
Українські вибори він називає демократією у дії,
а саме голосування в умовах війни - неабияким досягненням.
Проте щодо лідера перегонів - доволі скептичний.
Нам не слід намагатися робити прогнози з приводу потенційної програми
і порядку денного можливого президента Зеленського.
Нам слід дочекатися другого туру. Думаю, він і сам не знає, яка його програма.
Водночас євродепутат Яромір Коглічек, який часто займає проросійську позицію,
скепсис не розділяє і результати першого туру сприймає доволі позитивно.
Виборці вирішили, що ці два політики старого покоління є нездатними.
Тож вони віддали перевагу комусь невідомому в політиці.
Це добрий сигнал, бо ми можемо очікувати руху в позитивному напрямку.
У програші в першому турі новачкові Володимиру Зеленському
чинний президент Порошенко винен сам -
у цій думці сходяться і європейські політики, і преса.
Люди, які протестували на Майдані, бачили у Порошенкові вісника надії,
попри те, що він був міністром за часів Януковича,
є олігархом і володіє кондитерським концерном та телеканалом, пише німецький таблоїд Bild.
"Порошенко не зміг виправдати довіру дуже великої кількості людей.
Занадто мало реформ, занадто багато скандалів, жодної реальної боротьби з корупцією,
недостатньо змін у країні".
Петро Порошенко асоціюється зі стабільністю, а для когось навіть із застоєм.
Тоді як Зеленський - з протестом, з чимось новим у політиці, пише австрійська газета Die Presse.
"Що означає цей несподівано добрий для Зеленського результат?
Коротко кажучи, виборцям набридло.
Симпатичний анти-істеблішментський кандидат Зеленський символізує протест, відчай і надію".
Натомість німецька Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung зауважує:
Зеленському вдалося мобілізувати протестні настрої, при чому не агресивною,
а дружньою передвиборною кампанією.
Водночас, що являє собою сам кандидат - поки незрозуміло.
"Представленої суспільству політичної команди немає,
а від змістовних запитань журналістів він ухилився і вдень виборів.
Багато виборців голосували не стільки за нього,
скільки за того чесного та ідеалістичного президента,
якого вони знають із популярного телевізійного серіалу".